are you open to doing a little um
game uh which with with me
always okay we're gonna play a little
game called
is it a little weird with jenny slate
i know with that foxy music
okay um is it a little weird
to sing personalized songs to your pet
in a baby voice no it's important
it's important it's not weird it's
important to sing
tiny songs to your pet you know in any
voice
but i would say singing songs to the pet
is like that's like a daily essential
okay is it a little weird to smell your
own burps
you know i don't think it's weird i
think everybody kind of does it
like as a reflex but it can be
personally devastating
you're right um is it a little weird
for an adult to sleep with a stuffed
animal
it's all about the context
there was a time when i was single and i
did sleep with a stuffed animal but i
also
traveled with the stuffed animal so it
was kind of like a comfort thing
um that i had when my dog wasn't there
but to each person their own
journey with their dolls and stuffed
animals that is exactly my motto
is it a little weird to watch reruns of
the same tv show
over and over instead of watching a new
one
no certainly not you know what i mean
that's like having a favorite flavor
if you really love your grandmother are
you gonna like visit her one time or as
often as you can as often as you can she
makes you feel good
okay that not only was clever
it's true i love bananas jenny slate's
little weirds
is available in paperback now it is just
so wonderful
as are you jenny slate thank you
thank you thanks for having me and
congrats on your show
jenny thank you so much